hello everyone I'm pleased to announce
my new tour for
2024 beginning in early February and
running through June Tammy and I an
assortment of special guests are going
to visit 51 cities in the US you can
find out more information about this on
my website
jordanbpeterson.com as well as accessing
all relevant ticketing information I'm
going to use the tour to walk through
some of the ideas I've been working on
my forthcoming book out November 2024 we
who wrestle with God I'm looking forward
to this I'm thrilled to be able to do it
again and I'll be pleased to see all of
you again soon
bye-bye so the the moral confusion here
is that you have many well-educated
people who uh will make very fine grain
distinctions
about uh moral Norms in the context of
you know living you know in 21st century
America you know they'll they'll
consider words to be violence and you
know
the misgendering of people to be a
profound microaggression but you ask
them to consider whether you you know
someone like malal ysep ey was badly
treated by the Taliban and they become
Tongue
[Music]
Tied hello everyone today I have the
opportunity to talk to Sam Harris Once
Again Sam and I have spoken many times
and usually publicly in the past trying
to sort out our mutual understanding in
relationship to such topics as while
morality fundamentally both Sam and I
are convinced to the core of our beings
you might say that there is a true and
not merely relative distinction between
good and evil although although we
differ to some degree in how that
distinction might be characterized and
what the fact of that distinction means
with regard to belief and so every time
I talk to Sam I'm interested in trying
to understand for example what he really
means by objecting to the religious
propositions that he does object to as
one of the horsemen of the new new
atheist movement so-called especially
given that Sam is all so uh committed
to what you might describe as a
religious practice he's an avid
meditator and certainly believes that
spiritual experience is not only real
but perhaps the most real uh form of
experience that's available to us so
we're going to Hash through that again
to try to distinguish between dogma and
knowledge to try to distinguish between
religious exper experience per se or the
religious experience that's valuable and
a counterproductive totalitarian
dogmatism and to try to lay that all out
with foray into the domains of well
meditative practice and with the
occasional description and discussion of
the political so it's good to see you
again Sam and I think the first thing
that I will ask you about is I'm just
curious we haven't talked for I think
it's almost a year now I believe that's
the case and so the first thing I'm
curious about is what what are you up to
uh it feels like two years I feel like
our last conversation was in the in the
very depths of covid and uh I was in
some basement Lair uh so I I I have a
it's got to be two years um things are
great I mean it's really a nice time of
life it's just it's nice with the family
it's nice professionally it's just a I'm
in a good spot it's a you know I'm all
too aware that things can change so I'm
enjoying my moment in the Sun but uh
it's really it's really a beautiful
period of Life yeah so what's good I
mean my my in terms of just how I spend
my time dayto day it's uh really has
become a uh a semi seamless machine for
producing well-being I mean it's really
I'm doing what I want to do moment to
moment
and um finding lots of people who want
me to do it so it's it's just um there's
not much distance between what I have to
do certainly professionally and what I
would do anyway just because I want to
do it so it's um I just I count myself
as extraordinarily lucky to have found
my U my path here and and that it's
working so it's it's um yeah I I just
have I have no I have no complaints it
would be indecent to complain about
anything personally at this point except
for the the passage of time and and the
implications of that which
which I I know all too well yeah well I
would say that you look both younger and
happier than you did the last time I saw
you and you know I I got quite attuned
in my clinical practice to watching
people's faces obviously but but also
seeing to some degree the way that
they're set habitually you know and you
look you look very good and so I'm I'm
very happy to hear you said something I
I think that is of particular interest
to me is that you have managed and also
attribute this to some degree to Good
Fortune to bring together what you have
to do with what you would want to do and
that seems to me a sign of optimality of
function well as well as the good
fortune that we just described and so
what is it that you think that you're
doing that's enabled you I mean I know
that you've been concentrating to a
large degree on meditative practice for
example but what is it that you think
you've done to the to your attitude
let's say to your patterns of attention
that have enabled you to bring what you
need to do and what you want to do in
alignment well um this has been
happening for quite some time it's you
know this is I would say that this has
been you know it's taken me 20 years to
fully get my my professional life and my
core interests to gel and so part of
that is having built out platforms where
I can just follow my interests as and
and follow the the needs of the moment
you whether it's Jour responding to
something that's in the news or just
figuring out what um what I'm most want
to pay attention to in a given day or
week uh so I mean as you know I have I
have both my podcast making sense and I
have the the app waking up which is you
started at narrowly focused as a a
meditation app but it's much more of a
an applied philosophy app at this at
this point it's just expanded Beyond
meditation and it's exp expanded Beyond
well beyond my contributions to it so
it's um there are many other people on
it and so I can I can bounce between
those two platforms you know however I
see fit and they're and they're while
superficially they're similar because
they're
just me pushing MP3 files out to the
world they're just just a audio uh
Platforms in the
end they're totally unlike one another
with respect to the kinds of topics I
tend to engage and the kinds of
interactions with the world that
provokes so it's it's it's really quite
it's almost like I'm living two lives
simultaneously because I'm waking
up the app I
get it's it's no exaggeration to say it
it's it's
it's almost uniformly uh just pure
positivity coming back at me you know
apart from the the occasional you know
software glitch that you crashes
somebody's phone and we hear about that
it's just there's no distance between
what I'm intending to put out and the
effect I'm hoping to have and the effect
that I I in fact seem to be having based
on the feedback so and this was you know
this has
been uh was launched almost exactly five
years ago so for five years I've had
this look at this kind of alternate life
it's almost like a a counterfactual life
to the one I I hadn't managed to lead
where I could sidestep
all pointless controversy and
annoying U you know bad faith criticisms
and just meet
people at a place where what I have to
give is found valuable by them in in
precisely the the way that I would hope
right so it's just it's like a a purely
positive encounter with with Legions of
people um which again because of my
experience as an author and as a
podcaster I had lost sight of that even
being a possibility right I just I had
lost sight of the fact that there are
people in this world who have careers
where they don't get any grief from the
world because the world just understands
what they're putting out and they like
and people like it and they get paid for
it and it's just it's a it's a
transaction that makes everybody happy
and so it's like opening a bakery where
everyone loves the the scone and you
know it's it's just it's you know
there's just nothing bad about it um and
and yet I find you know and this you
know I'm sure you feel the same way I
can't stay merely in that lane because
there are other topics of social
importance that I feel a need to comment
on and so I have my podcast and public
speaking or or books or any other
channel by which to do that and and you
know mostly I'm I'm doing my podcast for
that but so I still have a foot in the
water of
controversy um and I'm sure we'll get
into some of those controversy
controversies here but it's to have both
is such a a um a source of Sanity I
because I can I can just swim in
whatever Waters I want to swim in on a
daily basis so it's it's it's quite
wonderful
um so why do you just out of curiosity
so while there's there's a substantial
parallel I would say between the
situation you're in and the situation
that I'm in given what you just
described because one of the reasons
that I continue to tour continually
essentially is because it's completely
positive and I I engage in almost no
political discussion almost no culture
War discussion almost all of it is well
you're uh you talk about your waking up
um system and I
suppose I'm walking on a parallel line
in so far as I'm encouraging people to
aim up and I don't know if there's any
difference between waking up and aiming
up perhaps there is and we can talk
about that but it is a great relief to
be in a domain that's entirely positive
and then but then it is interleaved for
me as it is for you with some degree of
combat let's say on the more
philosophical and culture War side of
things how how why have you concluded
sometimes I wonder Sam if it wouldn't be
just as well to stay in the positive
domain all the time and I know that you
are no longer on Twitter for example and
so that's obviously one of the places
where you've detached yourself from the
proliferation of you might say
unnecessary and polarizing conflict but
you just did indicate that you feel
either a moral obligation or an
intellectual pull towards keeping
a breast of the domain of life that
constitutes more problems and so why do
you think that balance is necessary why
don't you forgo that entirely and stay
within the domain of the positive I mean
you seem to have concluded that
balancing them is actually better for
you in some sense or maybe better in
general so why did you conclude that
yeah well it's a question I continue to
ask myself because um you know you only
have one life or you you know I would
say you only have one life you can be
sure of and so why not live it in the
the happiest manner possible
um but I do find that there are certain
moments first of all my interests are
are are wider than can be encompassed
just by things like meditation and and
narrowly focusing on on questions about
how to live the the most meaningful
possible life right it's not it's not
all just
about maximizing mental pleasure
or um even one's you know ethical wisdom
moment to moment there's things that
interest me that I want to talk about
that really don't belong over at waking
up but they do belong on my podcast so
talking about you know physics say right
that's just interesting and and I like
to do that um so there's that um as you
say I I I deleted my Twitter account
which is you know is a an important part
of the answer to your first question of
just what has gotten better for me in in
the last 12 months um that was you know
I'm I really am embarrassed to say what
a life hack that turned out to be to get
off Twitter you know we can talk about
why I did if you want but uh the net
result has
been almost unambiguously positive I
mean there's there's a slight sense you
know certainly when the things in the
news are are really heating up that I'm
I could be missing something or you know
I'm not party to the conversation that's
happening at at that kind of interval
you know where people responding to
things every every 30 seconds but the
the truth is I don't have to be because
I you know that what I found is that
when you don't have an opportunity to
just blurt out your instantaneous
response to something that's happening
in the news or something you saw in your
timeline and you have to let that let
your response to it cure over the course
of days in my case because you know I
have to decide okay is this important
enough for me to actually talk about it
on my podcast
and I might not be you know podcasting
again for another three days or even a
week and so many things don't survive
that test that you they just they just
98% of things just fall by the wayside
because the truth is you didn't have to
broadcast your opinion about that thing
that happened on that campus you know by
that you know that indiscretion
committed by that stupid blue-haired
person right so it's just like you you
didn't have to weigh in and you didn't
have to reap all of the the attendant
poison of having weighed in and you
didn't have to worry about whether you
should respond to that poison and those
those misunderstandings generated there
and I noticed in retrospect that and I
dimly I dimly knew this when I was on
Twitter but I didn't fully appreciate it
until I was
off that it was no exaggeration to say
that that basically every bad thing in
my life you know apart from you know the
sickness of the people close to me um
was a result of something I had done on
Twitter or or something that I had seen
on Twitter relate to that that I felt I
needed to respond to so it was just this
kind of hallucination hallucination
machine that I had invited into the
center of my
life and getting rid of it
really modified my sense
of not not just what I have to do on a
Day-Day basis and what I should do but
just of my own existence right like
there was something about my digital
existence
that
was claiming too much real estate in my
my conception of myself as a person
right and well you you might have put
your you might have put your finger on
it at least to some degree there with um
something like your observation about
whether or not you're willing to put
time into it you know I've had many
discussions with my family about Twitter
in in particular and I would tend to
agree with you that much of the
negativity that I do run into in my life
is a consequence of Twitter and
so
now I use Twitter to stay a breast of
the sorts of things that you described
that you might be able to get access to
on Twitter as well current events and
there is that temptation to respond
immediately but you intimated that maybe
a rule A good rule of thumb is something
like if you're not willing to sit down
and think about it for an hour let's say
then perhaps it's not important enough
to share your opinion with millions of
people and reap the
consequential well and reap the
consequences you know and Twitter is
although it's it's a social media
platform that facilitates impulsivity
it's also a broadscale publishing
platform and it's not obvious that you
should
be publishing all your instantaneous
instantaneous responses to cultural
events and it's a funny thing for me
because it's not that easy to dissociate
that from responsibility you know I feel
that I have a responsibility to bring to
light let's say certain elements of the
culture war that are going on at a deep
level and and part of the reason that I
use Twitter the way that I do use it is
to do that but then it does have that
problem of intense negativity
and I learned from walking through
airports with my wife we had this
discussion a couple of times airports
have bothered me a lot ever since 9/11 I
review them as they're like the for me
they're the the bleeding edge of the
totalitarian incursion into General
day-to-day life and they've always made
me very uncomfortable I don't like
lining up for for for the in you know
for the for the screenings the
theatrical screenings and so forth and
that made me very and hard to get
along with in airports and you know I
had a conversation with my wife a fairly
detailed conversation and our decision
was if I'm in an airport and something
happens that that annoys me but isn't
important enough to actually sit down
and write about then I should I have to
just ignore it or shut up about it and
this has also helped me calibrate my
responses and it's the same problem with
Twitter right is that something can be
irritating and be genuinely irritating
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
the most appropriate way to deal with it
is to share your irritation in the
moment and part of the reason Twitter is
so pathological perhaps and is such a
snake pit of polarization is because it
does encourage that kind of impulsive
and immediate response to things that
are perhaps of sufficient seriousness so
that they should only be taken
seriously yeah it encourages many things
that I think are
ultimately producing some consequential
delusions for us individually and at
scale um I mean so so it is it it
provides a kind of an illusion of
conversation because you know you know
you'll tweet something at me I'll tweet
something at you and we seem to be
talking but as you know we're we're
primarily talking in front of our
respective audiences which are diff
which are largely different right so
when I say something to you you know
it's it's my audience is at my back and
and and vice versa so so much
communication becomes performative and
that starts to degrade the you know the
kind of the good faith characteristics
of a real conversation and people just
wind up scoring points on each other and
you so it encourages that that's the
kind of thing you know dunks or the kind
of thing that tend to go viral um it
selects for a kind of dishonesty like
there's an ethic where you know they're
very few people feel a real need I
certainly any anyone who's any kind of
activist politically left or right
doesn't feel much of a need to really
get their opponent's position correct
before savaging it they they they don't
mind distorting it especially if they
can use clips of their opponent that
have been artfully edited so as to to
make them seem to be saying something
they weren't in fact saying in context
they they will use that as a way of just
smearing the person you want to hold
someone account able for the for the
worst possible version of what they
might have said however implausible it
it really is as long as that can be made
to stick and people just see what can be
made to stick and they almost never go
back and clean up their you know
apologize for their errors and and and
uh go back and clean up their mess and
people do this you know people you know
when blue check marks meant something
there were a lot of blue check marks who
would behave this way right and and you
have journalists and or people who are
treated as journalists and I you know as
a point of principle really have always
tried to avoid that I mean whenever I
get somebody somebody's views
wrong however odious I find their views
or how odious I find them as a person I
I you know I apologize for that and
correct the record but I found myself
continually in dialogue with people who
didn't play by those rules um so it's
set up to bring out the worst in us and
to and to degrade
conversation way more fully than it's
ever degraded in person I mean the thing
that convinced me to get off Twitter is
that I was seeing people behave like
Psychopaths by the you know the tens of
thousands and I knew there couldn't be
that many Psychopaths right I knew there
wer I knew these people couldn't be this
dishonest or malicious in their lives
and in fact in many cases I knew this
because I I knew some of the people I
had had dinner with some of the people
you and I had you you have mutual
friends and and colleagues among these
people um and yet I was seeing the
absolute worst in them in terms of how
they were engaging on Twitter not just
with me but with other people who you
know they felt they needed to to slam um
and I we're seeing some of this I mean I
think there's something like this
happening I haven't really followed it
but over the daily wire I mean you're
you know very close to you've got
Candace and Ben attacking each other um
I would argue that that that kind of
thing is not only spilling out onto
Twitter it would it very likely wouldn't
happen but for the existence of Twitter
and there are many things out happening
out in the real world that happen in
response to something that's seen on
Twitter but then the the you know like
some of many of these protests these Pro
Palestinian protests that that have
become
so such concern to many of us especially
on you know college campuses where you
have otherwise very educated people
expressing solidarity with with
um true ethical monsters
uh in Hamas um what we're seeing is
something's getting provoked by imagery
on Twitter uh however half-baked uh and
then the response to it in the streets
is is
performative because it is it you know
it's it's meant for the streets but it's
really meant to be broadcast back on
Twitter right I mean that people
wouldn't be doing these things but for
the omnipresence of cell phones that can
be that can be broadcast back onto
social media and so I I just think we
have built this reinforcement cycle for
ourselves it's kind of feedforward loop
of of that has eroded our capacity to to
speak rationally to one another and to
have good faith debates and and even
even strong arguments and it's produced
a um a machine for for amplify
amplifying the narcissistic tendency of
everyone wanting to just manufacture
outrage so yeah well that's well you
know I think there's something and
you're pointing at this I actually think
there's something that's that that
technically going on particularly with
Twitter and maybe it's proportionate to
the degree to which a social media
Communication System capitalize on immed
capitalizes on immediacy of response
like I'm afraid that we're setting up
virtual
environments their virtual perceptual
environments and communication
environments that aren't
well matched to the underlying reality
which means they're delusional and the
delusional direction of Twitter is in
the direction of enabling psycho
Psychopathic Behavior now there's a
research literature that's emerging on
that so you see the people who are most
likely to troll online so to cause to to
post things that they know perfectly
well will do nothing but cause trouble
are dark tetrad types they're mellian
narcissistic Psychopathic and sadistic
and then so it does bring those people
out of the woodwork to a much greater
degree than might be otherwise expected
but I also think as you pointed out that
it does the same thing to those
fragmentary Psychopathic tendencies that
exist in everyone it's a it's a
psychopathy facilitator and the degree
to which that is driving polarization in
the broader culture is determinate I
think it might be driving almost all of
it right right because my my online life
and my real life are so different that
they almost bear no relationship to one
another like and and I I suspect this is
something that you said you've been
discovering particularly as a
consequence of working in the waking up
space you know I mean all the
interactions I have with people in
public in my actual life are
unbelievably positive with the exception
of perhaps one in 5,000
now the one in 5,000 can be quite
unpleasant but it's statistically
negligible but if you derived your
expectation of my experience from the
online World you'd expect that you know
half the people that I ran into would be
people that hated me and simply the dis
the the lack of concordance is so
remarkable that it does look like it
does look like the difference between a
delusion and reality I think it's
unbelievable dangerous like we have no
idea what it means to compress people to
the point where their communication
tilts heavily in the psychopathic
direction we know have no idea what the
broadscale social consequences of that
might
be yeah I so I feel so I share your
experience again my Encounters in public
are almost uniformally positive I think
the um obviously there's a possibility
of a selection effect there the only
people who are likely to come up to you
are the people who have something nice
to say and then you have you have other
people who are recognizing you who are
just you know holding their tongues and
they and they they don't like you um and
you you know we're both controversial
figures and I I have to think that that
some percentage of the people who notice
Us in public are people who are not fans
and just don't say anything but still I
I've seen the
effect you know I I've I've joined the
the the the two the two groups and I
know what it's like to deal with the
same person on Twitter in front of their
fans versus over dinner and it's you
know they're miles apart and I I just
see
there's um so so it is corrosive even
when even even in the best case when
we're not talking about Anonymous trolls
who are hiding behind you know their
anonymity and just savaging you these
are people with real reputations who you
know you you actually know and and will
likely meet again in person and yet
Twitter brings out the absolute worst in
them I for me the the very large the 800
PB Canary in the coal mine for me is
Elon I mean look at what Twitter has
done to elon's life right it's just you
know Elon used to be a friend you know
he's somebody I knew reasonably well
um you know his engagement with Twitter
has
been catastrophic for him as a person
from my point of view I mean it's just
it's clearly a compuls compulsion I mean
he was so addicted to it that he felt he
needed to buy the platform um but it is
a you know his use of it has been so
irresponsible and uh produced such
forget about the harm he's produced in
other people's
lives how and nothing I'm saying now has
relates to changes he's made to the
platform I mean that's that's a separate
thing that we can talk about you know
I'm I've always been agnostic as to
whether or not he could actually improve
Twitter as a as a platform and he may
yet wind up doing that but I'm just
talking about the way he has personally
used it as a user of the platform and
the way he's interacted with people and
boosted signal boosted
massively um the profiles of anonymous Q
andon lunatic trolls right I mean he's
he's been completely Cavalier and who he
interacts with all the while knowing
that anyone he boosts suddenly gets you
know a million followers and has a
platform that they otherwise couldn't
imagine having um so
I look at him and I think okay if if
someone of his talent who has so many
other good things to do with his 24
hours in any given day uh is is this
derailed by this platform you know is
this is using it this
compulsively to the
obvious degradation of his reputation in
most circles that count right I mean
he's you know he's
not he can't be canceled because he's
produced so many useful things you know
and he's just too embedded with things
that everyone still wants but man if he
if if he were a little less productive
you know in space and and on the ground
um we would never you know he'd be he'd
be the next Alex Jones in terms of the
way mainstream culture would view him
um and it's it's been terrible to see
right has been very depressing to see so
um and it's and I you know I I guess I
can blame him but I blame the stimulus
more I blame Twitter I blame I blame I
mean for whatever reason he has found
this to be the most addictive thing in
his life and
um and he's he's been willing to totally
torch relationships over his use of
it let me ask you this question are you
at peace with the mindless screen time
you spend on your phone every day are
you gaining that higher quality of life
you know you desire if this sounds
familiar I have good news starting on
January 1st tens of thousands of men all
over the world will start 2024 with a
90-day journey together in search of a
more purposeful life it's called Exodus
90 and it was built to help men enjoy
the freedom of becoming who they were
truly made to be Exodus 90 guides you in
removing the attachments that are
holding you back from a better life and
it actually Works independent research
shows that Exodus 90 men report
considerable shifts after the 90 days a
dramatic decrease in time spense on
their phone stronger satisfaction rates
in their marriages a more meaningful
relationship with God and true
brotherhoods of men on the same path for
the past 8 years Exodus 90 has helped
more than 100,000 men build their own
road map for living with virtue in a
culture that offers far too many paths
to self-destruction so is it time for
your Exodus we start January 1st find
resources to prepare for Exodus 90 at
Exodus 90.com Jordan that's Exodus
90.com Jordan to start your
journey yeah well it's definitely the
case that one of the Cardinal dangers of
Twitter is its propensity to bring out
the worst in people and and the worst in
the culture I mean I guess it's an open
question whether or
not musk's takeover of Twitter will
result in the dramatic improvements to
the platform that might justify the risk
inherent in engaging with it so let's
leave that a bit Sam I I want to I want
to turn my attention our attention if
you don't mind to some of the deeper
issues that you and I have discussed and
I have a bunch of questions for you so
the first thing I want to do is clarify
something my recollection of
particularly our last conversation and
it was one that I found clarified my
understanding of your thought to a
greater degree than our previous
conversations I had we had probably
because I listened to you more was that
and so correct me if I get this wrong
because I want to use it as a platform
to ask you some other
questions my understanding after that
conversation was that you were driven to
search for a an
objective foundation for moral claims
primarily because you had become
convinced of the existence of
for lack of a better term of evil in the
world and we're looking for a for Solid
Ground to stand on in your attempts to
both understand and
combat the most malevolent proclivities
of the most malevolent proclivities we
could leave it at that now is that is
that a reasonable is that a reasonable
conclusion have I got that right yeah I
think my motive is will be pretty
familiar to you I this came largely out
of the collisions I was having
with uh people after I wrote my first
two
books the end of faith and letter to a
Christian Nation where I was noticing
disproportionally on the left uh
specifically I we've come full circle
now to this moment you know in the new
cycle U but um you know mostly in
response to my criticism of of Islamic
extremism and uh you know the the kind
of the urgency with which I was I was
saying that the Islamic doctrines of
martyrdom and Jihad are you know are
sincerely believed by millions of people
and these beliefs have real consequences
in the world and they're not good ones
right and and we should should talk
about that honestly what I was getting
mostly from the left was
um you know what what struck me as pure
masochistic delusion but it was on its
own side a very sophisticated philosophy
of you know postmodernist truth claims
about the the relativity of everything
and which which you know in the minds of
its adherence left us with no Solid
Ground to stand on ever when making
claims about right and wrong and good
and evil uh so you know I the point
where it it became and this is something
that I this is actually a scene I I I
wrote verbatim in my third book the
moral landscape which is where I I laid
out you my my argument on this on this
topic
um I was at the so Institute at a um a
conference that had been organized it
was either in 2006 or S I believe uh and
I had said something disparaging about
the Taliban in my remarks about the the
relationship between uh moral values and
and our our growing scientific
understanding of the human mind and
human
wellbe and I said you know something you
know that I should have been
uncontroversial in that context I'm at
the sock Institute this you know
preeminent scientific institution down
in La Hoya which is you know one of the
nicest places on Earth um and
uh you know with an auditorium filled
with um you know well healed uh people
who are appear to be enjoying their
political freedom and and their freedom
of speech and freedom of everything um I
said something about uh well you know we
we just know whatever we whatever
remains to be discovered about the
nature of morality and and human value
and human well-being we know that the
the Talib the Taliban don't have it
perfectly right right so if whatever the
optimal way of living is we know that
the the Taliban haven't found it right
we know that forcing half the population
to live in cloth bags and beating them
or killing them when they try to get out
is not an optimal strategy for
maximizing human
well-being and then a a um a woman
academic uh and she actually happened to
be or was later a scientific adviser to
to President
Obama uh for medical ethics came up to
me and said well that's just your
opinion right and so then this this this
this led me to to realize just how far
the rot had spread you know that even
here here is someone who is you know a
woman academic uh who's enjoying all the
freedom of of you know however hard one
uh that can be found in Western Society
uh presumably this is a person who would
be who would have um responded to the to
the me too movement and and and all its
moral urgency with with alacrity he was
still open-minded at least in the
context of talking to me about the
treatment of women and girls under the
Taliban right and I you know I I I
detail our our further conversation
again
verbatim um in my book because I
literally I was so ounded by The
Exchange that I I I turned on my heels
literally in mid-sentence walked
straight back to my room and wrote down
exactly what the two of us had said
because I just could not believe um what
had happened
uh
so so the the moral confusion here is
that you have many well-educated people
who uh will make very fine grain
distinctions
about uh moral Norms in the context of
you know living you know know in 21st
century America you know they'll
they'll consider words to be violence
and you know the misgendering of people
to be a profound
microaggression uh you know Halloween
costumes that culturally appropriate etc
etc or anathema this is this is how
finely calibrated their moral Scruples
are over here you know in the quad of an
American
University but you ask them to consider
whether you you know someone like malal
ysep ey was badly treated by the Taliban
and they become Tongue Tied right they
they they and they will even say things
like well who are we to criticize inan
culture so anyway so that motivated me
to say all right the smartest most
well-educated people in our
society have become unored to any vision
of um objective moral values right they
have you know worse they have it they
have become anchored to a belief
that objectivity with respect to moral
values is impossible and certainly
science will never have anything to say
about it and so they've seed this ground
to dogmatic religion right and and
someone like Stephen J G did this when
he he had this conception of the
non-overlapping magisteria between
religion and science right so science
talks about facts and and what is but
religion talks about what should be and
and all and the totality of human values
and I think that's you never been ATT
tenable way of dividing the the pie um
and but has this obvious defect that
where people who lose their religious
convictions are then left standing on
apparently nothing when it when it comes
time to say something like slavery is
wrong I you literally have professors
saying well you know I don't like
slavery I don't happen to like it I
wouldn't want a slave but you know I
can't you know I can't really say it's
wrong from the point of view of the
universe right I me it's that's that's
not the that's not what science does and
my point is that morality and this is
perhaps something you're going to want
to to um disagree with but in my view
morality H morality has to relate to the
the suffering and well-being of
conscious creatures I not even limiting
it to humans but just whatever can
possibly suffer or be made happy in this
universe is some is a a possible theater
of moral
concern and we know that mind that
conscious minds must be arising in some
way in Conformity to the laws of nature
I mean so whatever is possible for
conscious Minds is a statement about at
at bottom a a final scientific
understanding of what minds are and what
Consciousness is and how those things
are integrated with the physics of
things um and so there there have to be
right answers to the question of how to
navigate from the worst possible
suffering for everyone to places on the
moral landscape that are quite a bit
better than that where there's there's
Beauty and creativity and joyed of A
Sort that we can only dimly imagine and
the question of how to do that and what
that landscape looks like those are
those are it's a fact-based discussion
about science at every level that could
be relevant to the conscious states of
conscious mind so it's it's a statement
it's a discussion about genetics and
psychology and neurobiology and
sociology and economics and and any and
and Sciences as yet uninvented with
respect to causality in this place and
so that's that's my argument that
there's we need a we need a spirit of
consilience um across this this this the
domain of facts and values and um yeah
there's more to say there but I'll I'll
stop okay okay well so I'm G I'm going
to pick up a couple of themes
there so one of the things that that you
pointed
to was the incoherence manifested by
this woman and and like people in
relationship to micro narratives and
macro narratives so you said
that it was your in your opinion that
she or the people who she might
represent would be perfectly willing to
be upset about some relatively minor
issue that might arise on a University
campus like the wearing of inappropriate
Halloween costumes
but are incoherent in relationship to
making broader scale um moral claims now
one of the claims of the
postmodernists This was um put forward
most particularly by who was it now who
said that there were no meta narratives
the postmodernism is fundamentally
disallowance of the idea that any
uniting meta narratives are possible
I'll remember his momentarily it could
be dared or Fuko
yeah no it's it's it it's not he he he
he's the guy who generated simulation
Theory another
Frenchman it's aard
Bard SP okay so here's the problem with
that um well the problem with that in
part is that there's no United action
and perception at any level
without a uniting narrative so for
example if I just move if I pick up a
glass to move my a cup from the table to
my lips I have to organize all those
extraordinarily complex actions right
which Cascade up from the molecular
level through the musculature of my body
I have to organize that into something
that's coherent and unified in order to
bring about any action whatsoever and
what that implies is that there's a
hierarchy of uniting structure and what
the postmodernists do is arbitrarily
make that halt at a certain level it's
like so you're allowed a uniting
narrative or structure up to a certain
level but beyond that you're not allowed
it at all and that's the point at which
the meta narrative emerges and those are
now forbidden and I don't understand
that because I think that it's an arbit
a distinction between a narrative and a
metad narrative is a is a it's an
arbitrary distinction and you can't
attend or Act without a uniting
narrative so now you're you seem to be
pointing to something like that so let
let me walk through your argument you
you pointed to one I'll add one other
which I think is a simpler defeater
which is that they the claim is there
can be no Universal values right and a
universal truth claim for the respect of
right and wrong and good and evil and
yet they tacitly make the universal
claim that tolerance of this ethical
diversity is better than intolerance
right so so there so the demand is we
need to Toler we need to find some space
in our minds to tolerate the difference
of opinion offered by the Taliban or
Hamas or some other some other group of
that sort um but that doesn't make any
sense that's that's an appeal to
tolerance one that they you know the
Taliban and Hamas don't share right so
we're tolerating their intolerance uh
but it's a it's also the tacit claim
that tolerance is better you know
Tolerance on our own side is the uniting
narrative sure yeah well you see the
same thing with the postmodern
insistence this is particularly true of
people like Fuko that nothing rules but
power right because Fuko saw power
making itself manifest everywhere and
the fundamental postmodernist claim is
that there's no uniting meta narratives
but that didn't stop the postmodernists
for a second in making the claim that
you could find power relations
underlying every single form of Human
Action and social interaction so but
this now this meta this uniting
narrative see you you point to it in a
way that I think that that points out to
me a very fundamental element of
agreement between the
positions that you and I have taken even
though we've had so much apparent
disagreement you point to the Taliban
and you say at minimum we can say with
some degree of certainty that what the
Taliban are doing is not optimal okay
and you said that's a claim that's so
weak in a way that it should just be
self-evident right you know what I mean
by weak it's like isn't that obvious
well you know I started in my
investigations at a more extreme point I
would say I looked at the campu in owitz
who enjoyed his work and thought I don't
know what good is but at minimum it's
the opposite of whatever the hell that
is and so that that was a starting point
for me and it seems to me that partly
what you're doing is that you put your
foot firmly on the head of evil and say
well this is a starting point and even
though we can't Define good we can
Define it as the opposite of whatever
that whatever this is and so does that
seem like a reasonable point of
agreement between us yeah as far as
you're concerned yeah although I think
this this is perhaps a a different topic
but it it it um certainly adjacent to
what you just said I think there's some
ethical paradoxes here which would be
interesting to consider because I I
think most of human evil of the sort
that you and I are now describing
doesn't require the presence of actually
evil people right I think there are evil
people I think there are true
Psychopaths and sadists who for whom
it's you know it is true to say that if
evil means anything it you know it
should be applied to their their
conscious states and their psychology
but so much of what we consider to be
evil and so much so much of what
produces needless human misery uh is the
result of otherwise normal people
psychologically behaving terribly
because they believe fairly crazy and
unsupportable things about you know what
reality is and how they should live
within it so you I would I would by no
means ever want to suggest in fact I'm
at pains to to say otherwise whenever I
can remember to that you know all
jihadists or even most jihadists or all
Nazis or even most Nazis are were
Psychopaths right I mean that the horror
of these belief systems is that they is
not that they act like bug lights for
the world Psychopaths and you and you
attract a lot of people who would be
doing terrible things anyway and they
just they just happen to start doing it
in this new context let's say under the
Islamic State um no you you certain
ideologies attract totally normal people
who would otherwise be totally
recognizable to us psychologically and
socially as good normal people but for
the fact that they be conv they got
convinced that you know what whatever
the the relevant Dogma is you know in
the case of okay okay well so I would
say that's another point of agreement we
we it seems to me that that the the
pathological the systems that produce
rapid movement towards social and
psychological
pathology both facilitate Psychopathic
behavior and attract the Psychopaths I
would say it's it's both of those you
can have both of those operating at the
same time right and so then what we have
are people we have systems of
ideas working in the background and
those systems of ideas draw people into
their orbit and motivate them to do
things that un under the influence of
other systems of ideas they might not be
inclined to do seem reasonable yeah and
also I just note in me you might want to
leave this aside but you your
description of a a a guard at aitz who
enjoys his work um I think it's tempting
to
imagine that that guard is incapable of
all the ordinary forms of happiness and
life satisfaction that we would
recognize in ourselves because of what
he is spending his time doing and and I
would say that's that's obviously not
the case I mean so so the and and there
there can be virtues expressed toward
evil ends I mean just just imag just
just unpack the meaning of that phrase
the guard at alwiz who enjoys his work
right so like there there's the do you
know the
um um I think it's just called the aitz
album did you ever see the the these
photographs that were taken they were
found attic I mean it's one of the most
amazing documents Nostalgia for owitz
yes that's for sure absolutely well and
I think you're your in your insistence
that we can't merely write off that
pathological Behavior as a manifestation
of a kind of auman psychopathy is
extraordinarily important right because
we have to contend with the fact that
these systems of ideas are capable of I
think possessing is the best metaphor
and that's something I want to get into
into you with you that those systems of
ideas are capable of possessing people
who are in no way indistinguishable from
the normal from normal people and
sometimes not indistinguishable from
from people with all sorts of laudatory
uh traits I think you mean not not
distinguishable you said sorry yeah
sorry not just yes yes yes yes so yeah
but just sorry sorry to keep derailing
you Jordan but I would just add one more
piece here that one thing this suggests
is that mental pleasure though it is
though it is often taken as a sign of
the kind of moral rightness of of our
current
preoccupation isn't such a sign I mean
you could there's such a thing as
pathological ecstasy right you can feel
Bliss well sadism sadism is a great
example of that yeah and so so I would
just say that so you can imagine the
suicide bom or before he detonates his
bomb if he's if like many of them he's
doing that with the sincere expectation
that in the next moment he will be in
Paradise um there is a kind of
exaltation and and even
self-transcending quasi
spiritual uh positive affect there that
you just have to grant that the human
mind is capable of of being pointed in
the wrong direction ethically and and
feel very good about it the holidays are
rapidly approaching but we can find
peace and calm in the craziness of the
season with hallow the number one
Christian Prayer app in the world
immerse yourself in Christmas in Advent
prayers meditations and peaceful
Christmas music hallow also offers an
extensive library of Bible reading plans
accompanied by insightful Reflections
and audience guided meditations whether
you're a seasoned Bible reader or just
starting your journey Hall provides a
platform for you to engage with
scripture like never before a great
place to start is with father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year in which he
offers brief daily readings and
Reflections available on the Hallow app
the Hallow app also helps you connect
with a community of like-minded
individuals sharing experiences insights
and encouragement along the path to
spiritual growth this Christmas join
Hallow's Christmas prayer challenge
Advent with CS Lewis for the 25 days
leading up to Christmas you can focus on
the real reason for the season with
prayer meditation and Christmas music on
hallow download the app for free at
hall.com Jordan for 3 months free that's
hall.com
Jordan well positive emotion of the
incentive kind mediated by dopamine is
associated with movement towards a a
posited goal and so what that means is
that false goal produces false enthusias
false goals produce false
enthusiasm essentially by definition
right and so that's actually by the way
as far as I can tell the moral of the
story of the Tower of Babel by the way
is that you can build pyramidal
structures that reach to the sky that
are predicated upon either false goals
or false assumptions and the consequence
of that is the creation of a state of
disunity and misery so comprehensive
that people can no longer communicate
with one another so now these system see
Sam the reason I brought this up in part
is because
my meditations on the influence of
systems of ideas I thought about these
as systems of animating ideas that I saw
a very strong concordance between the
action of systems of animating ideas and
archetypes and so that's why I started
to become interested in archetypes and
so the I would say that the one way of
conceptualizing the POS The Possession
the ideas that possess people that
motivate them in a pathological
direction is that they're possessed by
ideas that are archetypically evil and
so here's here's the question I have for
you and I my sense is that you and this
is the same as Richard Dawkins is that
you guys identify
the spirit that motivates people to act
in a in a pathological Direction the
Taliban you identify
that with the religious with the
religious
impulse now is that a fair
characterization well I would say that
it's not exclusively religious but in so
far as it is religious it gets even more
leverag in in that context and to to
worse ends so for instance you know what
is worse about jihadism than you know
ordinary forms of terrorism in my view
it is the religious Top Spin it all it
has based on the the its motivating idea
so the fact that it is is in principle
otherworldly the fact that it is you
know just anchored to to prophecy and
belief in the Supernatural all of that
potentiates it uh in the you know
further in the wrong direction so like
you know the troubles in Ireland would
have been made worse had the Irish
Catholics also been suicide
bombers uh expecting to go straight to
heaven because there was a a passage in
the New Testament which said you know if
you die while killing uh pagans or Jews
or any other
non-Christian uh you'll you you'll find
yourself at the right hand of Christ in
the next moment right so like that like
it's better that there's not a passage
like that in in the New Testament and
it's better that that that you know
quasi
religious
political um source of of terrorism in
the
UK was not uh potentiated by a clear
connection to religious belief and
religious expectation okay so your claim
is is something like the the
uh the possibility of relig ious
justification for an unethical act has
the side effect of elevating the status
of that of the claim to morality
associated with that evil act to the
highest place so let let me put that in
context so there's a there's
a injunction in the Ten Commandments
it's either the second or third
commandment I can't remember which that
you're not to use the lord's name in
vain and
it's the same injunction that pops up a
couple of times in the gospels where
Christ tells his followers to not pray
in public and to not be like the
Pharisees where their Good Deeds can be
seen in public and so the
first the first injunction the the
Commandment is pointing out a deadly sin
and the sin is to claim to be acting in
the name of what is most high when all
you're actually doing is pursuing either
your own motivations or even worse the
your worst possible
motivations and your claim seems to be
that the intrusion of religious thought
into the ethical domain allows for those
claims to be put forward thus magnifying
their dangers is that is that a
reasonable way of putting
it well I think I'm it it depends on the
specific instance we're talking about
but I think what I'm saying is um is
even more pessimistic than that it's
that it given the requisite
beliefs it's possible
to create immense harm consciously
create immense
harm without even having bad intentions
toward anyone I mean it's not it's not
that your bad intentions and your your
hatred of others somehow gets um a a
sacred
framing by religion that that also
happens and that's a problem but in the
worst case you can actually be feeling
compassion while creating terrible harms
right like you you can feel nothing
certainly no ill will at all for the
people you're killing so I mean to take
the extreme case there there are cases
where jihadists have blown up crowds of
children you know Muslim children uh on
purpose
uh for for variety of reasons I mean
there were cases in you know where they
were there were Western soldiers handing
out candy to crowds of children in in
the war during the war in Iraq at one
point and you know a suicide bomber
would would blow that whole scene up and
and the whole point is point is is
manifold but it it's it's obviously to
kill the soldiers and produce those
casualties but it's also just to create
the the horror and and apparent
untenability ility of of the whole
project in Iraq right it's just like
this is these are people who are going
to blow up their own
children uh what possible good could we
do here trying to build a nation right
okay okay but just just just to close
the loop there I'm not I'm not imagining
that the per the people who did that
actually hated the children right they
just believe they believe that there's
absolutely no possibility of making
aoral error here because the children
they know are going to go straight to
paradise they've actually done the
children a favor by by the light of
their beliefs yeah okay I okay so I well
I'm perfectly willing to accept that
modification so you're basically saying
that not only can you use the most high
as a justification for your actions and
and as a consequence produce all the
terrible dangers that are associated
with that but that that can actually
twist your moral compass so that acts
that are truly High are are seen as
manifestations of what's best okay so
here's here's the problem as far as I
see it Sam the contradiction here that
I'm trying to work out is that on the
one hand we have this situation where if
there is no reference to a higher good
or a lower evil because I'm going to
assume those are basically the same
thing you end up in a situation where
you can't do anything but take a
postmodernist stance in the face of
let's say the Hamas atrocities or the
atrocities of the Taliban or the
atrocities of oswit because there's
nothing higher to point to against which
to contrast those patterns of endeavor
but if you do pait something that's of
the highest then you run into the
problem whereas you just pointed out
that you can use your hypothetical
alliance with what is now deemed to be
highest to just ify your own evil
actions but also
to skew your moral sentiments so that
you take positive pleasure in the let's
say in the suffering of others even the
suffering of innocent children so
but now on the one hand if you drop the
notion of the highest good you end up in
the morass of moral relativism and on
the other hand if you accept it then you
end up in a situation where you can
justify the worst behavior in reference
to the highest possible good is that is
that a
reasonable portrayal of the of a
conundrum I I don't find I think that's
a needle that we can easily thread um
and so and the way I would do it is just
to say that there's obviously higher
good and it's also obvious that we don't
know we don't fully know its character
right so that like we know that things
can get better and they get quite a bit
better and quite a bit worse and we know
that better and
worse um maybe that's as
multi-dimensional as you want it to be
right there's not not just one it's not
just for instance it's just not it's not
just a matter of more pleasure say it's
not just a matter of more physical
health it's not just a matter of more
love it's not just a matter of more so
we can you know extend your list of
desirable things as long as you want but
we know that this
universe offers in the space of all
possible Minds and all possible
experiences there is there there are
places of unimaginable suffering where
and and where that without any Silver
Lining there's no good that ever comes
of it it's just you know a functional
hell right um we know even within the
context and and and conversely we know
that there's just experiences of
of of beauty and creativity and
inspiration and love and gratitude that
we you know that those of us who have
had them you know either in meditation
or on psychedelics or you know in other
Peak moments in life you know we just
find ourselves tongue tied in the
aftermath trying to capture what what
was going on there so we know that these
extremes
exist we know that there are things that
we can do individually and together to
maximize the the the likelihood of One
Versus the other and so if good means
anything if if right and wrong mean
anything um it means navigating into
this space of of better and better
possibilities for not not just
individually but but together and so
what I would say is that we don't need
to know exactly what the highest
possible good is we just have to know
directionally that it's you the
implications of moving right left up or
up or down right so if I told you well
there's a button we could press now we
have a new technology is a button you
can press that makes
um excuse me we just make everyone on
earth a little less happy right with
nothing that nothing good ever comes
there's no Silver Lining to this it's
just everyone just gets a little
crankier a little dimmer a little um um
less satisfied a little less creative a
little less appreciative of of their
Good Fortune a little you just go down
the list and we just decrement you know
all the good
things just by a little right now it
just we just know
that it would be bad to press that
button right that I guess that would be
a bad thing to do if we could engineer
some neurotoxin to spread all over the
world that would make people a little
bit less good in all kinds of ways and a
little bit less happy um a little bit
less intelligent a little bit less
creative okay that that would be a bad
thing right directionally right and we
don't have to know the ultimate
negativity or the ultimate positivity we
don't have to know just how good human
life could ultimately get without any
possible residue of of
improvement um we just know
directionally that you know where from
where we stand the Taliban are making
things quite a bit worse even though
they think they're making them better
right so like like we know that it's
possible to look at a specific human
project right for you know standing on
the outside of it and say okay these
people don't know what they're missing
right and by and by extrapolation we
know that there must be some place to
stand to look at our current
projects uh by which it would be valid
to say okay these people you know now
talking about you and me and all of our
you know mo most enlightened friends
these people don't know what they're
missing right there's something there
there are things that that they could be
taught that they could learn
technologies that they could invent
intuitions that they could suddenly have
epiphanies that they could have that
would Orient them in a direction that
would be propitious that would would
make things better in ways that they
they have not even begun to imagine
right and so I think that the horizons
into which we need to press again
individually and collectively so it's to
make those ethical and PSY olical
discoveries um they're all you know
they're all around us again this is a
multivariate landscape but I just think
we don't need to know what the perfect
looks like or even that the perfect
exists to know directionally that that
that that claims about better and worse
are real and and that they matter okay
okay okay so let let me take you up on
that because I'm having now I'm having a
hard time
distinguishing some of your claims from
what I would regard as fundamental
religious claims so let me ask you a
couple and I'm not I I said you know I'm
I'm trying to make things clear I'm not
trying to push you into a corner I I
don't want to do that at all so I I
actually think that we agree on a lot
more than we disagree on and that we've
come to very similar conclusions from
very different directions okay so let me
ask you this so you know there's this
there's this Medi medieval
idea that God is the sum of all good
and I don't think some is the right
qualifier I I want to ask your you your
opinion about this you listed you made
two claims in your last speech in your
last bout of of response I think one
claim was
that you listed a variety of
attributes that were morally good and
then you made the claim that even if we
don't know what the good is in the final
analysis we do have a strong sense of
directionality and so one of the things
I've suggested to my audiences for
example is that there are some things
that you are doing and you don't know
whether they're bad or good and so you
can just leave those in AB bance for the
time being but there is a subset of
things that you're doing that you know
full well are not to be done that you
could stop doing
and you could just stop doing them and
see what happens and I've never met
anyone who doesn't have some knowledge
of that latter category right you said
you had it for example with Twitter you
know you noticed that consist okay so so
all
right let's go after the first claim
that you made you listed positive
attributes so I might say that do you
believe that there is a implicit Unity
underneath a list of positive moral
attributes so that if you took Beauty
truth love gratitude you had mentioned
love and gratitude for example and
Beauty if you if I said well is there
something in common that unites Beauty
truth love and gratitude what and it
wouldn't be the sum right it's more like
the gist it's more like the essence it's
the commonality of Goods that like and
it seems to me Sam that merely the fact
that you can use a category like good or
bad or good and evil within the category
of good are things United by their
participation in the good and so does is
there anything about that claim that you
find offputting well I would there's
some analogies we could use to capture I
I do think of these things as kind as
almost facets of a single Jewel right
and and so the facets are different it's
talking about you can talk about beauty
and not talk about love in the same
conversation that you can have a
coherent discussion of of of beauty
without reference to love and and vice
versa but when you're talking about the
the the conscious states that that
maximize one's appreciation of all of
these things and participation in all of
these things it's easy to to to Intuit
it that there's a there's a common
structure to the whole picture and so
yeah so a jewel with its facets is is is
is one analogy I would use but I would
also but but but just but I want to
subvert that for a second because I you
know my view my view of the moral
landscape is
that it's very likely a landscape with
multiple Peaks right and multiple valys
and so this can sound like moral
relativism in the sense that you know
that you know you and I might be you
know climbing the same Peak over here as
Homo sapiens in a you know Western 21st
century context but you know at some
great distance from ourselves there
there are possible minds and perhaps
even real Minds that you know could
exist in another galaxy or or that we
could create you know artificially
Etc that are organized on very different
principles and uh yet have conscious
states that admit of again right and
wrong answers with respect to the
variables of suffering and well-being
you know and you can you could you could
conceive of those as capaciously as you
want but there there could be
possibilities of happiness and
creativity and amazement that we can't
imagine because we don't have the
requisite Minds right like just there's
just nothing about our current minds or
even the likely path we're going to take
when we when we um augment our minds
technologically or genetically in the
future um we're just going to miss these
spots on the landscape and yet these
Landscapes have these spots have the
same Peak and Valley structure and there
could be Peaks that if we if there was
if we were more omniscient than we are
or ever going to be we we would be able
to compare these two peaks and and say
that it's better to be you know one is
higher than the other with respect to
certain variables um which is I just I
just don't think it's all random I think
there is structure there in in among
possible experience given whatever the
the natural laws are that that determine
the nature of experience in this or any
universe but the most relevant thing for
us is what does our local region look
like you know what what is what is an
obvious uh mode of descent into
pointless horror for us and how do we
avoid that and what is an obvious um
local Peak that we should be aspiring to
get to uh but even this analogy you
beget some troubling possibilities which
I which I take as at least potentially
real which is that it could be true to
say that there is an adjacent Peak to
where the one we're currently climbing
which is quite a bit better than than
the one we're attempting to climb quite
a bit higher with respect to well-being
and insight and creativity and
everything every other good thing but
the only way to reach it from where we
currently stand is to descend into some
Valley that's quite a bit worse to in
order to climb that that adjacent Peak
um that at least is you know I'm not
recommending that we spend a ton of time
thinking about that but that that's at
least conceivable me no I think we could
I think we could spend a fair bit of
time thinking about that so you know
there there's well there's a line of
mythological speculation that's very
tightly in keeping with the process and
the vision that you just laid out okay
so first of all you made the case that
you you Ed the metaphor of a
jewel and then you you said I would
rephrase I'm going to recast this in
some in somewhat symbolic terms and you
can see if this is a metaphor that
captures what you were expressing you
could imagine that they're jewels of a
beauty and value that are as of yet um
unknown to us right so we could agree
that there is a a Unity of good that's
Transcendent and ineffable and that the
goods that we see array in front of us
are prox proximal Echoes of that
ultimate Vision now your point is that
now and then we may be somewhat diluted
in the specifics of what we're pursuing
and that might blind us to a higher
order uh Transcendent reality then you
also added an additional twist which is
while maybe now and then a descent is
necessary in order to to make the next
Ascent possible okay so couple of things
on that so there's an old alchemical
idea by the way that the philosopher
stone is a jewel in a Toad's head and
the idea there yeah well the idea there
was that and this is the this is one of
the central alchemical dicta by the way
it's inquilinus inventure which means
roughly in filth it will be found or to
elaborate slightly means that that which
you most need will be found where you
least want to look and that's a
reflection of the idea that you had that
now and then in order to get to the next
Pinnacle there has to be a dissent now
that's associated with something even
more
fundamental so there's also a of course
you know this idea is Central to Hero
mythology that Dragon's Hoard treasure
and that the larger the dragon the
larger the treasure and the idea there
is
that the more daunting the unknown
territory that you are presuming to
Traverse the more possibility there is
for Discovery and that the proper
attitude is therefore the one that
enables you to encounter that source of
unknown
wisdom in the most forthright and
courageous manner possible and so then
that there's a very int not to which is
that let's see how would I put this is
that the most valid source
of the most valid pathway towards
discovering that Jewel Beyond Compare is
a pathway that's marked out by the
voluntary willingness to confront
suffering and malevolence in all of its
forms now at that point these these
ideas to me these ideas start to become
indistinguishable from religious
presuppositions and so there's a
dovetailing here I mean you are
hypothesizing
that what's good has the metaphoric
quality of a jewel it's multifaceted and
it it's the things that it reflects are
more
tangible experiential phenomena like
Beauty truth love gratitude they're all
reflections of a higher order good you
made the case that that higher order
good may be higher order to the point
where in its extremes for extreme forms
it's ineffable right it's beyond our
ability to comprehend and describe you
made the case that we may be able to
approach that in something approximating
fits and starts and some of those fits
and starts may involve a dissent well
the religious injunction you see this in
cyclotherapy too is that the dissents
that are the precondition for a more
profound Ascent have to be undertaken
voluntarily right because you see this
in exposure therapy for example you know
if if people are stressed accidentally
by something that they're phobic of
their phobia gets worse right but if
they if they voluntarily expose
themselves to the stressor then their
bravery grows and their fear decreases
in a compens commensurate manner so one
of the things that I've been
well so I guess the first thing I'm
going to do is ask you what you think
about that so there is a a here's
another example Sam you tell me what you
think about this so there's a story this
is derived from this the tales of King
Arthur and the Knights of the Round
Table so King Arthur is sitting with all
the knights at the round table and they
decide they're going to go look for the
Holy Grail and the Holy Grail is the
container of the ever
replenishing liquid that's a good way of
thinking about it so it's either the
glass that Christ uses to represent his
blood at the Last Supper or it's the
Goblet that catches his blood on the
cross that's the background story now of
course the Knights of the Round Table
and King Arthur have no idea if the Holy
Grail exists which is a reference to its
ineffability let's say or of where it's
possibly located and so each night
leaves the round table and enters the
forest at the point that looks darkest
to him and that's where the quest begins
and so there is an idea lurking in these
stories that if you want
to Envision that Jewel the metaphoric
Jewel that you described then the
pathway to that is through the darkness
now you also said and you correct me if
I'm wrong about this that your journey
to whatever in Enlightenment you've
managed to find and and distribute was a
consequence of in some ways of entering
the forest at the darkest possible point
I mean you were grappling with the
problem of evil and looking for a
solution to that is that and it is it
not possible that that's a reflection of
this underlying idea that it is the case
that you retool your conceptions of
morality Itself by contending with the
things that most trouble and that are
most troubling and distressful be
tragedy and malevolence the things that
are in that realm does any of that seem
reasonable to you yeah so a few you
raised a few separate points there um so
first on the the notion of exposure
therapy being an example of a disent
into a valley so that you can Ascend
some other Peak I so I think that you
speaking individually for for a person
doing that that sounds totally plausible
to me there are all kinds of things we
do that make us uncomfortable but under
a larger framing we understand that
they're good for us and they're leading
us to to to grow in ways that that will
that will redown to our advantage in the
future so yeah so that's a you know
there are dozens of things that people
do and should do that uh make them less
than comfortable in the present that but
are nevertheless good for them you know
whether it's a medical treatment or it's
just getting in good shape or dieting or
whatever it is right um so there's that
uh the the place where I break from
religion I mean certainly a religion
like Christianity or Judaism or Islam is
just in the it's on many points but the
crucial point is just on the claims
about the unique sanctity and divine
origin of specific books right I mean
the moment you're going to talk about
all books as the products of
human creativity and
Ingenuity then they're all then then
we're just talking about the utility of
of of specific books and specific ideas
in in whatever context you know attracts
our interest and so we can talk about
the Bible we can talk about the Quran we
can talk about the the wisdom to be
found in those in those books and we
also can talk about the barbaric
injunctions that we want to ignore in
those books um and we must talk we must
evaluate the wisdom or the or the or the
barbarousness from by using our own 21st
century intuitions about what
constitutes wisdom now given all all the
challenges we face and what what
constitutes obvious barbarism that we
want to leave behind us and so that the
The crucial the thing that makes me an
atheist from a Christian point of view
or a Muslim point of view um is that I I
uh am unpersuaded by the textual claims
that anchor those two faiths and that
any real adherent to those two faiths
has to make in my view and in the views
of most you know adherence um and
but I would totally grant you that there
there are great stories in you know in a
thousand different books that we might
want to use uh to uh Inspire us to be
wiser than we tend to be right so you
could so you you know the L the King
Arthur literature that's seems totally
worthy of our
attention and they're there are um there
are many other good good um sources on
that on that particular shelf but no one
is taking the king or no one no one is
uh practicing suicide bombing or uh
fully deranging their politics over
their close reading of the the King
Arthur material right it's just it's
it's just the the literature is not not
doing that kind of mad work for us and I
think that's a good thing and so I I
want to live in a world where we
recognize that all we have communally
is the possibility of having a
conversation that can be more or less
persuasive more or less enlightening uh
and it's a conversation not just across
in the present you know with the the the
living Minds that are available but it's
a conversation with reference to the
greatest Minds that that preceded us
that of which we have some record you
know there many great minds presumably
that were are totally lost to us because
you know they they burn the library at
Alexandria
um
but uh we have this residue of past
wisdom and past Insight which is you
know the world's literature and we
should we should Avail ourselves of it
to our heart's content all the while
recognizing that this is a these are
just human beings having a a
cross-generational conversation about
important things uh and none of these
books is beyond criticism and Beyond
Beyond ignoring right and that that's
the crucial well you're you're you're
well your your fundamental criticism and
this is actually what I'm trying to pin
down in our conversation is that you're
you're pointing to the
misuse it's like the dogmatic misuse of
the
Traditions as opposed to their proper
use so there's a scene in the gospels
this is a very interesting scene this is
one of the things that gets Christ
crucified by the way is that he accuses
the Pharisees of
being the same people who put the
profits upon which their faith is
hypothetically predicated to
death right and so they don't take that
insult kindly but he's making the case
the same case you are as far as I can
tell which is that it's possible to use
the wisdom of the ages as a
justification for the use of force let
me give you another example of this this
is so cool you tell me what you think
about this I just did this seminar in
Exodus with a bunch of people we
released it on dailywire and on YouTube
and there's a scene in Exodus that's
extremely you extremely interesting
so Moses is put forward as the spirit
that eternally delivers from tyranny and
slavery that's a good way of thinking
about it so you could imagine MO Moses
is the embodiment of the force that
Wells up within you that inspires you to
speak out when the tyrants hold Sway and
it's the same voice within you that
calls you on your own slavish Behavior
anyways Moses embodies that and he's LED
his people in a rebellion against the
tyrants and now he's trying to lead them
out of slavery and they're in the desert
while they're trying to work this out
that's one of those descents before an
asset right so they left tyranny which
was an inappropriate mode of
organization they fell into the desert
which is an intermediary period That's
not the least bit Pleasant and they're
heading for the promised land right
which is the next Peak on the moral
landscape you might say now Moses has
been leading them
along you know in a very admirable
Manner and so this is what happens when
they get on to the border of the
Promised Land so they're right there
they're still in the desert they run out
of water yet again and God Moses goes
and talks to God and he says you know
well you've led us this far and we're
right on the threshold of Deliverance so
to speak but we're out of water and God
says to
Moses tell the Rocks ask the rocks to
bring forth
water and so he points out the rocks and
then Moses goes over to the Rocks but
instead of asking them
he hits the rocks with his staff and his
staff is a symbol of tradition of
tradition and
authority and it's it's the famous staff
of Moses and what he does is He commands
he uses Force to compel the rocks to
bring forth water instead of convincing
them to do so
verbally and he is punished very
severely for that because God tells him
that because he used Force where he
could have used the logos he could have
used linguistic
communication he can't enter he'll die
before he enters the promised land and
so it seems to me that your objection to
the religious is fundamentally given
your belief in a Transcendent good given
your belief in the reality of evil given
your notion that we do have an intrinsic
Direction ity given your idea that we
need to believe in
the the genuine existence of a moral
landscape is that your objection is in
the it's something
like an objection to dogmatism per se
yeah right and then and then we might
ask ourself well and that dogmatism is
the willingness of people to
use the tradition to what to drive their
own benefit to to justify themselves
without making the moral effort like how
do you think how would you go about
defining that inappropriate
dogmatism right it's also an attempt to
make the ineffable fully comprehended
right because the thing about a
religious totalitarian or a totalitarian
of any sort is that the totalitarian
will tell you that they have the truth
in its final form right that's the
really the totalitarian claim so what is
it about what do you think characteriz
is that fundamental dogmatism well first
I would point out that it's only in
religion that the the concept of
Dogma is uh not a pejorative in fact I
mean in the Catholic context it's
explicitly a good thing I mean there's
no embarrassment over their Reliance on
Dogma um it's a Catholic
term uh but everywhere else in our lives
we recogn I that it is intrinsically
divisive and not and incapable of
tracking the truth right something
that's held
dogmatically is something that is held a
belief that is held in spite of the fact
that there's no good evidence for it or
in fact in right in in opposition but
held why no but but I just want to I
want to nail this particular Point down
because this is this is the crucial
thing to to recognize in my you we we
understand in every other area of Our
Lives that this is not
um that this is intellectually not
only not pragmatic and not not helpful
and
not um not plain by the rules it's
actually indecent right it's the
antithesis of what we admire
intellectually right when you to
immunity to counterevidence no matter
how compelling is not a good thing
um intellectually and and ethically in
any secular context right so if I say to
you listen I believe X and there's
nothing you can say to convince me
otherwise and uh the more you no no no
matter how good your evidence gets no
matter how good your arguments get um
I'm not I'm not going to want to hear it
and if you press the case I'm going to
get angrier and angrier
until the the possibility of of of
having having a conversation about
anything fully erodes right that is the
status quo with respect to religious
sectarianism across the world it has
been that way for thousands of years and
it is still that way every Muslim
Christian Jew Mormon Hindu every
every true religious person of any you
know any
denomination to the degree that they
really are truly religious you know and
it's a faith-based
Enterprise
has said in advance of any conversation
on any topic listen there are a few core
things I believe and that my children
believe and I have taught them to
believe and I don't want you meddling in
any of that stuff right and I'm going to
get pissed off to the point of violence
or or at least I will I will be tolerant
of the violence of my
co-religionists if you push too hard on
this particular door the conversation is
over where these core principles of
Faith start right you're going to tell
me you don't Think Jesus was born of a
virgin and will be coming back to raise
the dead I don't want to fcking hear it
right and and I and that is our politics
even in America in the 21st century
we've got something like 45% of
Americans who are sitting there on their
Christian fundamentalism right um and
yes we can play nice on other topics
that don't strike a tangent to those
core beliefs but when you really begin
to push when you really say listen mom
and dad when we educate your children in
our school we're going to be telling
them things that is going to to make
this this claim about the Divinity of
Jesus seem more and more spous and more
and more ridiculous and more and more at
odds with everything we know about
biology and engineering and everything
else that we've learned in the last
2,000 years and you are going to look
like fools in the eyes of your kids for
believing these specific dogmas right
that's that's what's at stake here right
and people feel it and they are
resisting
and they're resisting with Medieval
tools right um and and everything I just
said about fundamentalist Christianity
in in America is much much worse in the
Muslim Community in a hundred countries
right
um you know there's there's no
comparison there we're dealing with the
Christians of the 14th century now I'm
not talking about all Muslims but I'm
talking I'm also not talking about just
1% of Muslims we're talking about many
many millions of people who hold to
their religious
dogmas like it's a life preserver in a
in a in a killing storm right and um
this is something we have to overcome
this we need a nonsectarian
conversation about the deepest ethical
and spiritual and scientific truths that
are available and which is to say a non-
divisive one one that is is truly
open-ended where we're not not making
adversarial recourse to to rival you
know commensurable claims from from
centuries ago were actually putting
forward the best arguments and the best
evidence in real time resorting to all
the best ideas that that can be
translated from every language
instantaneously now and it's it's a it's
a conversation very much in the spirit
of science very much in the spirit of
medicine say and it's not to say that we
we have the all that worked out as you
know we just went through a global
pandemic where people couldn't agree
about what the hell was happening and
whether vaccines safe or good or worth
worth inventing Etc but we know we we
can dimly see in that context where we
need to go and we which is we need more
evidence more argument better
incentives uh an acknowledgement of what
we don't know when we don't know it um
and we need to we need the conversation
to Simply continue and we know when we
look at it over our shoulder we know we
have made progress we know we're not
suffering for the most part you know
people being paralyzed from polio right
like we like there was once a time where
polio was was terrifying families
everywhere and for good reason and now
that is behind us except for a few cases
that have emerged up late because people
are afraid of vaccines of all types but
we know it's possible to make progress
in medicine right we know that progress
is not a matter of half of our society
saying that they're going to stay put
with the with the medicine of the of the
seventh century or the first Century BC
um and so it has to be with ethics so it
has to be with spiritual experience I
mean we're we're you know we're having
this conversation in the
context of a you know short period of
time where
where uh research on psychedelic drugs
has come back after more than a
generation of of of ignoring the promise
of these compounds um who knows what
possible benefits uh exist if we
if we explore
that that technology and that research
in the wisest and most judicious
possible way we know there Poss we know
we can create immense harm by doing it
badly we know we we know that in the 60s
just
broadcasting these these compounds onto
the population without any real
safeguards was um you know while I mean
some people's lives were improved but
but many people were harmed too and it
was the thing to which the backlash of
the last 40 years
um uh responded and there and then we we
lost a more than a full generation of
actually doing research on these
compounds but we're we're only at the
beginning of understanding what is
possible for us individually and
collectively as human beings
and understanding Consciousness itself
not even just human consciousness but
Consciousness as it is integrated with
the physics of things is
is among the most important things we
could do and it's and has implications
for everything we're now touching and
and and the guidance is not going to
come from the Bible and it's not going
to come from the the the you know from
Camelot either it's like we we need new
stories and new insights because we're
confronting new things I mean like just
take the take we don't have to spend any
time on it but just I'll plant the flag
here take artificial intelligence right
if if we don't know how Consciousness
arises in this universe and if we don't
know whether or or when it arises on the
basis of information processing we are
not going to know whether we build
conscious machines right I think we're
going to almost certainly we will build
machines that seem conscious to us
before we know whether or not they are
conscious and we will lose sight of many
of us will lose sight of whether it's
it's an even interesting problem to
wonder whether or not they are conscious
right they're going to pass the touring
test with such flying colors especially
especially when we're in the presence of
humanoid robots that look human and that
that are that are you know truly General
AI that we're just going to treat them
as conscious helplessly because we're
you're going to feel like a psychopath
doing otherwise and yet we're not going
to know whether we've built machines
that can suffer uh and we're not going
to know whether we're committing a
murder when we turn off a machine Etc
these are ethical problems that seem
totally speculative until you imagine
the possibility
of inadvertently building machines that
can suffer even more than human beings
can suffer right that would be a
monstrous thing to do and that is a
possible thing to Doc and it's something
we might just stumble into by not
knowing what we're doing in you know in
informational terms um so this is a this
is all just to say that questions about
the well-being of conscious creatures
are questions that we need to add addess
with all of the tools available in a way
that is truly Universal that gets that
gets Beneath The Accidental differences
of of a country a country of a person's
origin you know you it it doesn't it
shouldn't matter where you were born or
what what religion your parents were
that should that should not be the thing
that constrains your thinking about the
deeper truths here and so yes if if if I
don't deny that the world's religions
indicate something about the
possibilities of human consciousness
past and present and even the
possibilities of a Transcendent good to
which we should all Orient but it's it's
absolutely clear that we need a truly
Universal modern conversation about
those truths that do that that
ultimately ignores sectarian cultural
boundaries and and it's the sectarian
cultural boundaries that I worry about
well you and I have been have have been
trying to have those conversations you
know with some degree of success for
quite a long time let me let me ask you
let me ask you a specific question here
that that um how how do you
distinguish we've already agreed that
there's a problem when wisdom is
transformed into authoritarian Dogma but
here's a question like how do you
distinguish
between look you've already put forward
a set of hypothetically axiomatic
presupposition right which and and one
of them is that there is such a thing as
evil and another is that there's such a
thing as its opposite good and that good
has an ineffable quality in its final
analysis you could think about those as
you know they conclusions from the
conversation that we've had so far and
from all the work that you've done
obviously now you could imagine that
those conclusions could be turned into
well they are axiomatic in some ways you
could imagine they could be turned into
a kind of authoritarian Dogma in no time
flat like how do you and you know we
can't progress out into the world
without having a certain amount of faith
in our already extent knowledge how do
you think it's possible to conceptualize
the
distinction between knowledge as such or
even necessary knowledge and
Dogma well it's
um well do Dogma is clear in the sense
that it is it is truly inflexible right
there's no there there's a a stated
commitment to not revising this
particular belief or set of beliefs no
matter what happens right so for
instance for for Christianity or say the
Catholic Church you know the the
Divinity of Jesus is just non-negotiable
right it's like it's not there's not it
would no longer be Christian now I'm
sure there are a few groups of
Christians that would want to want to
push back here but generally speaking I
mean it comes from directly from Paul
you know if Christ be not raised your
faith is vain right it's like like there
there's a miracle at the bottom here and
if you are going to dispute that well
then really you're you're you're playing
a different language game this is not
you know this we're not interested in
that kind of innovation so Christ was
the son of God you make you struggle to
make sense of that if you want to but
but something like that has to be true
he he died for for your sins he was
resurrected he did not if if if you
found his bone somewhere um that would
be a problem um these are non-negotiable
tenants of the faith and you know Islam
has its versions and you know unhappily
for for the prospects of interfaith
dialogue one of the the core principles
of Islam is that Christ was not divine
right and to believe he otherwise is is
polytheism and that's a killing offense
right so right there there's a z Z some
contest between Islam and
Christianity so so so it's something
like it's something like it sounds to me
that it's something like a allowance for
doubt so I could imagine can imagine a
situation like this because because
there's still a confus one thing it's
not it's not just allowance for doubt
it's just
that it's um so so there are there are
things we
believe
that we can't imagine not believing
because of
how
uh how fully we are persuaded of the
legitimacy of the method by which we
arrived at those beliefs right so
there's a there was a methodology that
got us there now dogmatism is the
antithesis of methodology Dogma is not a
a statement of how good the method was
dog Dogma is just we didn't have a
method but this is so right it says so
in the book the book is perfect how do
we know it's perfect because the the
book itself says so right that's a that
bites its own tail that's not a method
that that is dogmatism and in my view
totally illegitimate but there are other
things that we believe right that we
would wouldn't say are dogmas but we
would also say I'm not going to waste
any time worrying that I might be wrong
here because I just don't see how I
could possibly be wrong now we know if
that in the context of those beliefs
it's still possible to be wrong right so
there there was a time where human
beings would have
said listen I've studied uid I
understand
geometry you know you're talking about
the possibility of more than three
dimensions it's obvious to me that
doesn't make any sense because I'm
standing here and I can't figure out
where I would point that isn't some
combination of up down left left or
right or front or back right there's
just there's three dimensions and my my
finger my pointing finger is all the
proof I need of that right so you could
imagine someone being absolutely
confident right but you could also
imagine that given the requisite
conversation with that person you could
you introduce them to the geometry of
reman and say okay space imagine space
is something that could conceivably be
curved right and it would be curved in a
dimension that is not just some
combination of up down left or right or
front and back Etc so there's a large so
there can be fundamental changes in our
view of things that are surprising
uh and and um and so we we can't we
can't rule that out in general no matter
how confident we are of specifics I mean
so one for me there's one thing that I
can't see any way
around um and I just don't you know I I
would admit that it's possible that I
don't know what I'm missing but I just
don't see how it would be possible so
I'm not wasting any time on it but for
me Consciousness what I mean by
Consciousness you know the fact that
anything seems to be happening at all is
the one thing in this universe that
can't be an illusion right so so there's
nothing you could say to me about how
wrong I am about anything that puts that
challenges this fundamental belief of
mine that Consciousness is the ground
truth of everything epistemologically
right so you could say well actually Sam
you're you're psychotic you know well
okay so I'm I'm wrong about everything
except this the way things seem that
demonstrates consciousness just as much
as as sanity would right like this is
like if I'm if I'm asleep and dreaming
and I don't know that well still this
dreamlike experience is what I mean by
Consciousness if the universe is a
simulation on an alien supercomputer
right and and and everything we think
about physics is wrong because we're not
in touch with the base layer of physics
right we're just in we're just a
simulation still what seems to be
happening in our case is what is meant
by Consciousness in my sense so cons so
so to say that Consciousness itself
might be an illusion right is it makes
absolutely no sense because any illusion
is another case of seeming it's a false
it's a false one by reference to some
other picture so I don't I can't get
outside of Consciousness
epistemologically and therefore it's you
know so anyone who would say so someone
might come to me and say well you're
being dogmatic in your assertion that
Consciousness can't be an illusion it's
not the same as being dogmatic I can't I
just can't can't see what to do with my
intuitions so as to even entertain the
alternative thesis that's not what any
religious fundamentalist that's not the
position of any religious fundamentalist
who's asserting you know the the unique
uh Divinity of the Quran or the or book
of Mor asserting an unwarranted
omniscience they're assert yeah they're
asserting a claim that that that is in
contact with many specific facts we know
about again you know
just real history or you know
terrestrial physics or anything else um
and I mean just you know this these are
points I've made before know you know to
the consternation of of Many religious
people but like you know the belief that
Jesus rose from the dead and and bodily
ascended somewhere and will be returning
to Earth at some point the the
historical person Jesus not some you
know not some anal ology to that person
but that's that's not just a religious
claim that is a claim about biology it's
a claim about human flight without the
aid of Technology it's a claim about
history it's a claim about I mean there
there are many claim it touches
everything we know or think we know
about science at some place and so it's
um and that's why it's it seems quite
unlikely to be true right if you're if
you're considering it dispassionate
um and I mean the other reason just to
now that you're you've brought it youve
poked this atheist and you're getting
you're getting the full file um the the
real the simplest reason uh why I am
effectively an atheist with respect to
Christianity Judaism and
Islam uh despite all of the other things
you think I agree with that that make me
a good C candidate for being sympathetic
to to with those
Traditions is that
the claim about the
books is so Preposterous given how easy
it would be for an omnicient being to
have proven his omniscience in those
books I mean if you just think of how
good a book could be had an omniscient
being written it all the things that
wouldn't be in there that would be
embarrassing now like you know
advocating slavery like he the creator
of the universe certainly could have
anticipated that we at one point would
have found slavery to be wrong right and
given us moral guidance on that point
but he failed to do that but even more
importantly it would be trivially easy
for an omniscient being to put a page of
text in there that would even
now be confounding us with its with its
um with its depths of of inspiration
scientifically ethically in every other
sense right so so so so so let let me
ask you about that moment so I'm going
to throw a spanner into the works maybe
we'll see well I've been spending a lot
of time writing in the last three years
again I'm writing a new book and I've
been trying
to extract out the gist of the biblical
Corpus let's say so I I have a
proposition for you and you tell me what
you think about
this
so as far as I'm concerned what the
biblical Corpus points to is a a
practice of it's a practice of of
sacrifice devoted to
atonement and so the idea we've already
talked on about this a little bit Sam is
that you know there are often things you
have to give up in the present in order
to make the longer term more functional
that's a sacrificial offering you might
say and so and that's the same theme in
some ways as that descent we talked
about prior prior to ascent and so
there's a pattern of sacrifice that's
that emerges as the cor biblical Corpus
progresses and the pattern of sacrifice
culminates in a
proposition and the proposition is this
that salvation and Redemption as
such are
dependent on the voluntary willingness
to confront the worst of of tragedies
and the deepest of possible acts of
malevolence that that's the universal
Pathway to Salvation and
Redemption and that's exemplified as far
as I can tell in the passion story so
I'll give you an example so I went to
Jerusalem with Jonathan pel and we
walked the Stations of the Cross and I
was and that culminated with a trip to
the Church of the Holy sepulture which
in principle at least in ition is
erected on the site of the crucifixion
and
so what seems to be happening
psychologically and I think this is
something that you can assess
multi-dimensionally in a consilient
manner is that the passion story walks
people through the necessity of
encountering the worst forms of tragedy
that can beset you in your life and so
that would be the the worst form of
tragedy is unjust suffering
fundamentally and the worst form of
unjust suffering is the most vicious
possible punishment delivered to someone
who's the least possibly deserving and
you know the times in your life Sam
where you'll suffer the most I would say
and you can dispute this but you can
tell me what you think is when you're
going to be bitterly punished even for
your virtues and if that's accompanied
by betrayal and the baying of the mob so
much the better and so the passion story
is a representation of the proposition
that in order to move towards discovery
of what's highest you have to
voluntarily accept the conditions of
unjust suffering that constitute human
existence and then there's a
mythological corollary to that which so
of course death by crucifixion is a
particularly unpleasant form of death
especially when it's brought about by
betrayal and at the hands of tyrants and
the mob which is what the story
encompasses but there's also an
insistence that the pattern that that
Christ acts out involves the harrowing
of Hell which is confrontation not only
with tragedy but with malevolence itself
and so the idea there is that and maybe
this is what's asserted dogmatically if
it's understood is that there is no
Pathway to redemp and salvation without
being willing to Hoist the world's
tragedies onto your shoulders and to
confront evil and so I'm I mean that's
the conclusion that I've derived from
walking through these stories and trying
to understand what they might mean and
that's pretty damn compelling that idea
and I actually think it's in some ways
in keeping with your experience because
you and I mean it's taken me a long time
to understand this repeated
conversations with you but it seems to
me that a huge part of your motivation
has been a consequence of your
willingness to contend seriously with
the reality of evil and to try to set up
uh what would you say at least to
investigate the nature of a morality
that might mitigate against that so well
I'll leave that at your feet for the
time being I me I'll give you response
which will indicate I
think the um what I consider to be the
the provisionality and and perhaps
even
um mistaken nature of of that the
framing you the Christian framing you
just gave um because I think it's
possible and perhaps even more useful to
view evil and I it's it's unavoidable to
talk about evil you know just as a
matter of shorthand in talking about
current events and I think and I think
we don't want to lose the term because I
think it's I think moral outrage is the
kind of fuel we need in at certain
moments and and and that's invoked by by
you know question framing things in
terms of Good and Evil
but I think it's at least plausible to
think of evil at bottom as being more a
matter of ignorance than anything else
and this certainly would be the Buddhist
framing of of evil I mean Budd Buddhists
don't tend to think about evil and
certainly the Buddhist teachings about
this weren't really a matter of evil
versus good it's it's more a matter of
ignorance versus wisdom um and even you
know Greek Phil Socrates I believe made
this point that you know no one
consciously or very very few people
consciously do evil I me but you have a
lot of people thinking they're doing
good in their own way um despite how
much harm they're
creating so the deeper problem May in
fact be ignorance and and one way of
seeing this you you can ask yourself you
take somebody take a quintessentially
evil person you know do do you have a
candidate for like the most evil person
uh you can think of
psychologically who's can you give me a
name Stalin Stalin's kind of Stalin
would be up there I would say so you
take
Stalin now at a certain point in his
life he was just a little kid right he
was just he was just this you know the
four-year-old Joseph who was in my view
I mean he could he could have been a
psychopathic kid I don't I don't know
about enough about his his biography but
and you know presumably he wasn't ay so
yeah presumably he wasn't a terrifying
infant you know but at a certain point
you had you know at a point young enough
in his timeline you have to just
acknowledge that he really is unlucky I
mean he's the kid who for whatever
reason you know genetic and
environmental um is going to become the
evil monster Joseph Stalin right and so
at what point along the way does he
actually become evil well that's hard to
spe if I mean there'll be moments in his
story where we can recognize right he's
now not a a normal much less normative
personality right he's treat he's
treating people sadistically and so I
don't know when that started but there's
a point before that where you think well
listen if there'd be any way to have
helped this kid not become this evil
monster we should have helped him right
we would have helped him if we could and
that would have been the right thing to
do right so merely hating him and
killing him would would would not have
been the ethically normative thing to
have done there because he's not yet the
person who created all the harms he he
goes on to create uh and but but I would
say that even if you go forward even if
you if you get him in his truly
malevolent form you know toward the you
the middle and end of his life imagine
what it would be like if we had Joseph
Stalin at his worst in
custody and we
had a a much more mature science of the
Mind available to us and we actually had
a cure for evil I just imagine what it
would be like to deliver this cure we
can actually just just modify all of the
receptor sites and densities and
Connections in the brain so to so as to
turn this malevolent sociopath into a an
entirely normal person with the normal
pro-social attitudes etc etc but keeping
intact his biographical memory and the
other aspects of his identity right so
so imagine being able to engineer the
following experience for Joseph Stalin
where you deliver him the the cure for
for all that ails him ethically and but
he has still has a memory he has he has
he has a knowledge of what you're doing
you've told him what you're doing and he
has the memory of all the stuff all the
malevolent stuff he did in his
past imagine what it would be like for
him to to wake up from the dream of his
sociopathy and experience for the first
time what it was like to be a normal
well-intentioned
decent human being right imagine what
that would be like imagine if you just
woke up tomorrow recognizing that you
had in this Fugue state of Psy
psychopathy over the previous year you
had killed you know 60 million people
and uh done other you know odious things
just imagine the Imagine the One the
feeling of of of uh regret to have been
at all entangled with that causality how
however you know little purchase you
have on it in the present because again
you're no longer evil but too imagine
the Gratitude of feeling of just being
rescued from that the the kind of mind
that would have been you know so
Cavalier about the deaths and IM
miseration of millions of people right
so that the fact that this is even
possible this thought experiment that at
some future date we'll have a a way of
curing evil people and that it would
make no sense ethically at that point to
go to go into our prisons and say well
we're going to withhold The Cure because
as as punishment for all the evil stuff
these people did it's like you know
that's like withholding the cure for for
diabetes for from you know diabetics the
moment we get it because you know of all
the the bad things they did when their
blood sugar was too low you know it's
just it justes wouldn't make any sense
ethically but that suggests a kind that
that ignorance is more
the problem here it's like evil people
because of the brains they have because
of the life lives they've had because of
the the if you want to add you know a
religious Dimension to it because of the
souls they have the souls they didn't
pick um they're unlucky to be evil and
unavailable to you know much of the the
human goodness you and I experience and
um if we could change that they would
they would be standing with us in a
position of astonishment that they could
have ever been those sorts of people and
so I think I do think you know at some
level the question of Good and Evil is
amenable to a to a different framing
which is more along the lines of of
wisdom and and
ignorance you don't know people don't
know what they're missing that's that
across across every possible dimension
of both intellectual and
ethical uh and relational you know and
and whole societies know what they're
missing and and figuring figuring out
what's missing and what and what we're
missing is is is all of our work yeah
well I would say we'll have to leave
that for a different discussion I would
say in response to that two things I
guess one is I think this is from the
Gospel of Thomas Christ said to his
followers the kingdom of God is spread
upon the Earth but men will not see it
or cannot see it depending on the
translation and then the other Germaine
comment might be with regard to
ignorance this is one of the things that
complicates it morally is there are none
so blind as those who will not
see and I mean I agree with you by the
way Sam is that the intermingling of
ignorance and malevolence is a that's a
very thorny problem right and which
precedes the other is very difficult
thing to determine so we're going to
have to stop I'd like to talk to you the
next time we talk Sam maybe we could
concentrate more on issues pertaining to
Free Will and ignorance that might be
very interesting yeah happy to do so all
right so yeah well that'd be good Sam so
for everyone watching and listening
thank you very much for your time and
attention I'm going to spend another
half an hour with Sam behind the daily
wire plus pay wall and so if you're
inclined to join us there please do that
gives you the opportunity I suppose to
throw some support support in the
direction of the DW plus people um who
are trying to put forward you know a
functional platform for new forms of
entertainment and for the continuance of
free speech so hypothetically that might
be worth supporting Mr Harris it's
always good to talk to you it's been a
pleasure getting to know you over the
years and I'm glad we've been able to
continue our conversations I really am
and too I appreciate what you had to say
today greatly and uh and uh till we meet
again yeah and thank you again one you
bet man all right
[Music]
ciao